-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated
writer and comedian
you know best from his work
on "Saturday Night Live."
The second season of his show,
"That Damn Michael Che,"
is out now on HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-Kim, why don't you tell me
why you think our relationship
didn't work out?
-'Cause you had a girlfriend.
-But what could I have done
differently?
-You could have told me
you had a girlfriend.
-That's right.
-Alright, alright.
Now, what do you think you could
have done differently?
-[Bleep]
What you just say to me?
-Be honest.
-You know, when we broke up,
he tried to date my sister.
-Wow.
-Well, I didn't know.
-Yes, you did. Don't lie.
-You didn't let me finish.
I didn't know that
that mattered.
-Huh.
-You're disgusting.
-He dumped me on Juneteenth.
-Really?
-I didn't even know that was a
[bleep] holiday until last year.
-Shame on you.
-Please welcome back to the
show, Michael Che, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome back.
-Oh, man, this is awesome.
Hi, Fred.
-Hi.
[ Laughter ]
-It is -- It is very kind of you
to come back into the building,
post-the "SNL" season,
because obviously you spend
a lot of intense months here,
and now you're on summer break.
-Yeah,
I did not want to do this.
[ Laughter ]
It's weird. Like, I love --
I love coming to the show.
It was always weird
coming back into the building,
though, not...
-Yeah.
-Like, I almost immediately
pressed the 17th floor
and all that.
-It is a trip that you --
Yeah, I mean, 'cause, you know,
we don't have a summer off
here on this show,
but you can totally
shut your mind off from "SNL."
-Yeah, it's hard to do,
but I encourage it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Although it is very strange
that you chose to use
your downtime from "SNL"
to do a second sketch show.
[ Laughs ]
We've talked about this before.
I'm so impressed because
I felt like I was just, like --
there was nothing left of me
after "SNL,"
and yet you have found time
to do two shows at once.
-Yeah, it's dumb.
-Yeah.
-I think, like...
[ Laughter ]
I guess it was sold to me
kind of like,
"Okay, what if you
could do a sketch show
where you can use
the n-word a lot?"
And I was like,
"That's different enough.
I could do that, yeah."
[ Laughter ]
-Now, just to make it clear --
in that clip we showed,
that's you basically
having a conference
with former girlfriends...
-Yeah.
-...getting notes on what could
make you a better boyfriend.
-Yeah, my ex-girlfriends
all sit me down
to give me an intervention,
but they don't know
that they're my ex-girlfriends.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, that's never -- obviously,
this is not something
in real life
that you would ever want
to have happen.
-Nah, it's a fantasy, though.
[ Laughter ]
Wouldn't that be cool
to just, like --
just, like,
get everybody together
and have them kind of all agree
as to why you're horrible?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I would like it on a --
On a person-by-person level,
I would like it.
I think I would hate them
collectively.
Like, reaching a consensus
about me, I think,
would be just devastating.
-But it would be so fulfilling.
-Yeah.
-Because now you don't have
to guess anymore.
[ Laughter ]
Like, you know
exactly what's wrong.
-What percentage of the things
that you're guessing
is wrong about you
do you think you're right about?
-Well, that's interesting,
'cause I do think that,
you know, like,
there are probably a lot
of things that's wrong, like,
that they would think is right
that's actually not true.
It's just me being,
I don't know, coy and elusive.
[ Laughter ]
But, no, yeah,
I would probably --
I would probably say like 75%.
-Do you think that --
I wonder if, like,
the criticisms of girlfriends
that had you at, like,
different parts of your life
are like massively different
just based on
where your head was at.
Or do you think
it's been consistent?
-I bet it's been consistent.
[ Laughter ]
I could hear --
like, you know, sometimes --
You ever, like --
You ever, like, get --
go through a breakup
and you almost hear exactly what
someone else broke up with you?
-Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
Like, you -- almost verbatim,
somebody broke up with you
for that same exact reason.
And you're like,
"Oh, no, she wasn't lying.
I guess I..."
[ Laughter ]
"I think I owe somebody
an apology."
[ Laughter ]
-Have you -- I've done this.
I'm -- I don't need to tell
everybody here.
I'll be driving with my wife
and my three kids in the car,
and I'll think of, like,
an argument I had with an ex
where I know I was wrong,
and I'll just go, "Ugh!"
[ Laughter ]
And my wife will be like,
"What?"
And I'll be like, "Eh, nothing."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, that's good.
That's...
I've -- Yeah, that's --
I've definitely had that one.
-Yeah. You --
So, we talked before --
the first season of
"That Damn Michael Che,"
you did at the same time you
were doing a season of "SNL."
-Yeah.
-This year,
was it a little easier
knowing what
you were up against?
-Yeah, well,
because the first season, like,
we didn't really know
what the show was.
-Mm-hmm.
-And I remember Tina told me
that, like, I -- I sent like,
Tina some episodes, like,
"Hey, what did you think
of the show?"
And she was like, "You don't
know what the show is yet,
but that's okay."
[ Light laughter ]
And I was infuriated,
'cause she was exactly right.
Like, after the second season,
I was like,
"Oh, this is what
she's talking about."
So, like, once you kind of know
what to do with it,
then you know exactly
how to write it,
and then you can
kind of delegate easier,
and it's so much easier.
But it was like -- yeah,
the first season was way harder
than this one.
-You have wonderful cameos.
Obviously, you have a lot
of talented friends.
-Yeah.
-I think that people think,
when you have talented friends,
it's easy to ask them
to do your stuff.
But it's -- I find it --
I always feel like they're being
asked a million things,
and i feel bad asking.
-Yeah, I hate asking people
for stuff,
'cause especially if it's,
like, my comedy.
'Cause I know
they're gonna be like,
"Alright, am I gonna have to
read about this tomorrow?"
[ Laughter ]
-You mean that
you're gonna put them
in this sort of jackpot
of getting in trouble?
-Yeah, like, oh,
maybe I shouldn't say this,
but I had, like --
we went up to, like,
Whoopi Goldberg for something,
and she was like, "Absolutely."
And I couldn't believe she was,
like, willing to do it.
So I had to tell her,
"Also, in that episode,
we have a Cosby impersonator."
And she was like,
"No, I can't do it anymore."
[ Laughter ]
Like, yeah, I should've probably
started with that one, yeah.
But, you know,
there's, like, always times
where, like, people want
to do it, but I'm also like,
"Man, you got to know
what the whole joke is."
[ Laughter ]
I can't --
-Yeah, never --
never let Michael Che
sell you on a close-up.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Like, you definitely want
the wide shot.
-Yeah, you got to --
you kind of got to know
what the punchline is.
It's definitely Bill Cosby
trying to make me a drink.
[ Laughter ]
Watch the show --
it makes sense!
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
No, I --
-In context, it --
-I think they get it.
Yeah.
-See, a long time ago,
Bill Cosby
would do this thing --
No, no.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, do you take a break now?
'Cause, obviously,
you're doing a little bit
of press for the show,
but it's done.
You got months off for "SNL."
Are you gonna take a break,
or are you
one of those workaholics
who's gonna start doing stand-up
again right away?
-I'm gonna do stand-up
probably next week, so...
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I just like -- It's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think everybody's happy
to hear that.
-It's always crazy,
because it's like --
like, my hobbies is my job.
-Yeah.
-Like, so, like, any time
I have free time,
I'm taking a break
from stand-up, that's it,
and then I'll go somewhere,
and I'm like,
"Oh, I wonder what
a show would be like in here" --
you know what I mean?
And then I end up at a --
doing this bar show in London
or something or whatever.
But it's like usually
trying to take a break,
the first thing I think to relax
is doing stand-up, so it sucks.
-You seem --
But, like, that makes sense,
because you have
a very relaxed persona onstage,
but do you get nervous
when you go do stand-up?
Like, if you're in London,
you're like,
"I'm gonna do a set at a bar,"
do you think to yourself --
as you're driving over,
are you thinking like,
"Is this going to work here?
Is this...?"
Or you're mostly
just really excited?
-No, I don't get nervous,
because the worst-case scenario
is people don't have fun.
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, honestly,
I hate to say this,
but it won't ruin my day.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Like, hey, some shows are
for you, some shows are for me.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, on behalf of everyone,
I do want to stress how much
we appreciate your honesty.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, congrats
on a great second season
and thank you so much
for being here, buddy.
-Yeah, thank you, Seth.
-We really appreciate you
coming back in the building.
-I appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Michael Che, everybody.
The second season of
"That Damn Michael Che"
is available now on HBO Max.
We'll be right back
with Kylie Minogue.